Yogi zuccaro was born into extreme poverty,
but ended up as the commanding general in charge of the entire Red Army during
World War Two today,
he is still considered by many in Russia to be the greatest military minds in
their entire history.
Yogi Zika was born in 1896 to an incredibly poor peasant family in the Kalunga
province,
roughly 80 miles from Moscow.
It's family had a house in the relatively poor town of Australia cove cow,
which is Yaakov was once quoted as saying,
look to the West in his village.
The family was rather tough when it came to discipline and it's floggings with a
bells by his father constant and were quite common in order to with his boy into
the shape that he wants it.
How are the young Zuckoff was not one to complain about things if there's a hard
life at a young age was one of the best teachers possible and to hard life.
It was something he certainly had the,
has one older sister named Maria,
but almost grew up with the younger brother as well.
Unfortunately,
his brother Alexi did not live past a year and his mother or Stingier was
absolutely heartbroken.
Then at the tender age of nine,
his life changed drastically in order to provide for his future and it's
probably also to have one less mouth to feed.
His family sent him off to work for his uncle Mikhail and Moscow is an
apprentice furrier.
While there was still a pretty harsh life and beatings were common,
if he didn't do what he was supposed to do,
he was still in a much better position relatively than he had been before.
He wasn't quite as poor.
He was exposed to Moscow society and he had a lot more education Vinnie would've
had otherwise.
In the year 1920 [inaudible] had his first marriage to a woman named Alexandra
Devenir,
Zuku Hoover,
who he would eventually have two daughters with named era and Ella.
However,
Zuckoff was not entirely faithful to his wife during his first marriage.
In the early years.
He has an affair with a young woman named Maria Volkova who had Matt while laid
up in the hospital while in the army during World War One.
They add an illegitimate child together named Margaret Rita,
but this didn't seem to have any real effect on zoo reputation at the time or
any point in his career.
In fact,
indeed later on in life,
he got divorced and remarried a woman who was called Galena Alexandra overnight
Samuel Nova,
and they had a daughter together called Maria,
which was his fourth and his lost child.
Zuckoff was actually doing quite well as a young man recently into adult who had
working as a furrier with a few young men under him.
But when world war one broke out,
since Russia needed able bodied mends,
it comes to the defense of their country.
Zuckoff was conscripted into the army or they've no account says that he had any
complaints about being drafted and he quickly found himself in an advanced
training program,
likely because it was a little bit more educated than most.
He got to start out training as cavalry and quickly rose up the ranks to
corporal.
During World War II,
he even managed to earn the cross of St George twice a Russian military honor
awarded for bravery from lower ranking or noncommissioned officers.
One award was for his caption of a German soldier runs.
Another was for taking a grenade explosion that left him in the hospital for
most of the rest of the war because he was in fact taken out of the war so early
due to injury.
He never really felt that his part in it was a tool significance Zuko of having
gone through so much poverty in his early life.
It never really been a fan of the SARS or the old political systems.
So when things started shaking up in Russia,
he founds himself fighting the old system.
When the,
sorry Nicholas,
the second abdicated things were in chaos and the provisional government took
over Yogi and the soldiers working with him decided to refuse to obey this new
government.
Since we're seeing branded as dessert is,
and they ended up on the run.
However,
once the Bolsheviks seized power as Uconn was once again able to leave the
shadows and join up with them as a soldier.
After several years of participating in mopping up actions against various rebel
factions,
he decided to join the Communist Party in order to further his career.
His steady hand as a commander as well as his background of poverty made him a
great asset for the new regime and its star continued to rise as he rose up the
ranks in the military.
He became more well known but is most decisive.
Early action was a situation most people aren't aware of in world war one in
which two years before the Germans actually declared war on the Soviet Union,
the Russians already have their hands full with the Japanese.
The Japanese had been adventuring into Russian territory for some decades in the
Russians had been struggling to push them back out.
The Japanese even reached so close that they could almost disrupt the crucial
Trans Siberian railway.
Japanese wanted more land and more island at the time.
They saw expansion into Russia as the best option to achieve their goals.
The Japanese had been having border clashes,
a rationale laid territory,
basically trying to sneak through their weakest points for almost a year when
Zuckoff who had been given command of the Soviet forces finally readied for his
first offensive where the Japanese had a mast or to the Galvin goal river,
he amassed over 200 artillery pieces,
over 500 planes and almost 500 tanks.
He had the greatest Ahmed offensive in known human history and in one big push
started barraging the Japanese position with bombers.
Following this,
there was an artillery barrage and then tanks finally in circling the enemy to
the point that almost no one escapes this security officer reputation as a great
leader,
able to move incredible amounts of new armored units effectively and earns him
special attention from Soviet high command.
There are some people who argue the zoo called exaggerated his role in the
battle of calc and Goldman's other battles as well in water to aggrandized
himself and that he got away with it because the Soviet Union wanted a standard
bearer and man's because he managed to get along well with Stalin.
One researcher named [inaudible],
who has written critically of Zuckoff claims that the real credit for the
strategy at the battle of Calkin goal should have gone to chief of staff as a
brigade commander named an a Bogdanov,
who was often considered to be the greatest leader that the Soviet Union had at
the time.
He also laments that most of the first officers or of our lesser leaders
involved seemed to still be classified as if the Soviet Union wanted all the
credit to go to Zuckoff.
However,
apart from the fact that Maa Bogdanov was a great leader at the time,
there is no reason to believe Zuckoff didn't plan or make his own decisions in
the battle.
He was the acting commander.
After all the slide criticisms and claims of proper credit,
he became stolons favorite general and despite occasional disagreements,
he quickly became Stalin's quasi official second in commands for the rest of the
war.
Now,
of course,
there were some major faults that Zuckoff had as a military leader.
Mainly he could often be seen getting very angry using a lot of foul language
and being abusive with people.
However,
this was not entirely uncommon for a lot of military leaders of the day,
and there is reason to believe that his men respected him because he actually
valued their lives.
One thing many people like to talk about about the Soviet Union is the casual
disregard that they had for the lives of their soldiers.
For example,
they'd just throw masses of infantry at fort to find positions with no proper
strategy and zoom call.
I've got a lot of the blame for this as the commander.
However,
he criticized these tactics and indeed said that it was criminal to throw lives
away in such a way.
And in another bit of writing he was a little bit less critical sounding,
but pointed out that skill and tactics would win,
was not throwing the people meet at the enemy.
General Zuckoff became very close to style in over the course of world war two,
but at least as close as you can get to a brutal dictator and gained a certain
respect for him,
whilst the Gulf may have been more critical of Stalin's influence and style of
leadership in his later life and memoirs at the time,
he has nothing but good things to say and seems to at least be mostly Anamund by
Stalin's growing cultive personality over the course of roughly 120 in person
meetings.
He got to know the man and felt that he had a good measure of him.
Some people fought that stolen,
could be too angry or too moody,
but Zuckoff seemed to prefer this.
He felt that Stalin's show of anger,
of frustration than other emotions were.
Just an example of him being exactly the sort of straight shooter [inaudible]
wanted to work with.
And he also felt that when Stalin was not moody,
he was very analytical and was always willing to listen to all viewpoints or
hear an arguments against his own ideas in order to better understand the
situation.
In fact,
Zuckoff newt stolen so well that he was said to be able to gauge his moods and
thus how to react by how stolen handled his smoking pipe.
If Stalin was smoking slowly taking long luxurious drags from his pipe,
it usually meant he was in a particularly good mood.
However,
if he didn't refill his pipe and it's it going again quickly when he was out,
it's Manti.
It was about to get very,
very angry zuckoff use these signs to help them know how to talk to start and
even when he was in a very bad mood at the battle for Berlin,
General Zuniga was in charge of the first velour Russian front and urged his men
to exact a terrible vengeance on the journalists.
They were entirely successful and finally defeating the Germans,
but also in terms of their vengeance.
As the Russian front moved into Germany from the east,
they brought terror upon civilians wherever they went with looting and rapes.
Being especially common off of the battle of Berlin generals who golf was given
the honor of presiding over the Soviet victory parade in Moscow in 1945 which he
happily took part in before being sent back to preside as the commander in
charge of the Soviet occupied Germany.
Zuckoff was quickly using his post as military governance have become good
friends with other world leaders like Eisenhower and increases influence abroad
by doing a really good job of taking care of civilians in the aftermath of world
war two in Germany,
stalling quickly became paranoid that zuckoff would become a political or a
military threat to him and removes him from this post,
bringing him back home to face challenges of disloyalty.
Stalin was himself.
A military commands it,
but from a day when there was no mechanized warfare,
even though Zuckoff was no real threat as he never had the political chops of
Stalin,
he was seen as a threat because he has an understanding of this sort of warfare
and a certain popularity within the military.
This was something that stolen would always be shadow self
when style and started a fair general Zuke off at the end of the war.
He decided to make an example out of him but not too big of one.
Considering his popularity,
Stalin did not think it wise to kill,
arrest or punish him too harshly,
but he wanted to put him firmly in his place.
Upon his return to Moscow,
he was raked over the coals and privately accused of disloyalty to the party in
order to take away his ability to potentially take over the government.
His position as commander in chief of the military forces.
It was taken away and he was sent off to a secondary position in Adesa or a much
smaller commands far from Moscow where he suffered his first heart attack not
long after he found himself back in Moscow for a time,
but the very barrier stylings,
radically loyal security chief was trying to find a way to destroy him.
Variant never trusted a man with so much military power and believed he could be
a dangerous threats to the cult of stolen barrier.
Finally,
it searched as it causes apartments in 1948 and found a huge true of treasures
that Zuckoff had taken back from Soviet occupied Germany without telling anyone,
despite its popularity,
it was a big hit to his reputation and Zuckoff was forced to publicly apologize
before finding himself being sent to an even more insulting,
and it's pathetic position in the Urals district policy of curves in life may
have taken quite a bad turn after the war.
It's could have been worse.
Barrier likely would have had him arrested or executed if he could,
but Stalin was not really interested in going that far.
Again,
it's Zuckoff whether for personal or politically pragmatic reasons.
The venturing barrier was one of Stalin's most radical followers,
so when Stalin died in 1953 many of the top leaders of the Soviet Union were
struggling to who would be the one in power and a group of smaller conspirators
works together to overthrow the last of Stalin's main influence in order to
destroy your barrier and Mallon Golf.
Molly Tov and Khrushchev match with Zuckoff and hatched a plan to arrest him.
That would be a major party meeting with many high profile members and at the
right moment,
zuckoff would come in with a few military officers and arrest barrier,
the arrest it went off without any hitch at all into barrier was taken away to
be accused formally of terrorism and counter revolutionary activities judged
officially and then shot for his crimes.
Zuko of likely placed a large portion if not all of the blame for the horrible
positions.
He had been increasingly relegated to you after Stalin's death as well as the
horrific embarrassment of the trophy affair on the shoulders of barrier was he
called,
didn't like to think he was guessing,
reads of the influence of the cult of Stalin's likely told himself that was part
of his justification.
He must have certainly got a lot of personal satisfaction out of the man's
destruction.
He even once said that arresting barrier,
it was the greatest thing he had ever done in his life.
While all is leading from the trophy of Fau wasn't exactly a great thing to do.
It is understandable for him to harbor resentment at having as lutes taken away
and is being forced to apologize for it.
As that kind of looting was quite common among the Soviet leadership after World
War Two after the death of Stalin and the arrest of barrier beating to the end
of Stalin's cult of personality,
Zuko soon found himself appointed as minister of defense.
Sunday Nick Align Bogan in.
During these years,
he'd tried to foster peace between the United States,
the Soviet Union,
and the rest of the wells being reluctant to take military action unless
absolutely necessary.
There's partly stems from long conversations that he had with Dwight d
Eisenhower with whom he had struck up a friendship years previously at the end
of World War Two Zuko took Eisenhower on a tour of the Soviet Union and an
Eisenhower even invited Zuckoff to America,
although he was not allowed to go on such a tall.
The two of them talked a lot and even corresponded through letters for years
after after meeting with Zuke,
often getting to know him so well.
Eisenhower actually believed that true and lasting peace with the Soviet Union
was entirely possible and he hoped that his relationship with Zuke often zuckoff
influence influencing governments and with the Russian people would help to make
that happen.
Unfortunately,
Zuckoff was such a reformist and continued to take power to himself in such a
way that those in charge became increasingly worried about him.
When Zuckoff wrote extremely critically of the cult of style in denouncing the
way the government used to be run under the old dictator.
Wily old Khrushchev used Zuckoff statements and popularity to institute real
reforms with himself as the head,
but at the same time he was worried about to cough.
The former general is now minister of defense was asking soldiers to go to him
first before any of the politicians,
and it's crucial.
Jeff had him removed as minister of defense in 1958 for fear of him becoming a
burner.
Potus after how badly Napoleon had thrashed and relatively recently and their
history,
the Russians fair to leader who would take from within using the military and
then run the country by military hates politicians like crease.
Jeff believes the zoom call was loyal and they loved to use the popularity that
he has with the people,
but they found these same traits dangerous to the continued political rule of
their country.
Unfortunately,
Zuckoff had today history of being used by politicians do achieve their own ends
and then being thrown aside later.
It's hard to say if this kept happening simply because the Zuckoff was hoping to
gain more political power,
but simply did not have the political skills or whether he knew he was unlikely
to gain any real power,
but simply did what he thought was best for the country at the time.
Regardless,
it would likely be quite a different world if zuckoff had had the political
skills to truly advance in the power structure that emerged in the Soviet Union
after World War Two if he weren't who have taken control,
his relationship with Eisenhower might've helps bridge the divide between the
two countries.
History might have turned out very,
very differently.
However,
things we're not all bad with Khrushchev and control until the end of his
premiership in 1964 Khrushchev was a tireless reformer who got ribs of a lot of
the repressive stolen as policies and try to bring more art and creativity back
to the country again.
When Brezhnev came to power in 1964 he also saw Zuckoff as so many had before
him.
Has someone he could use whilst you've off had been largely ignored under
Khrushchev.
There was under the premiership of bread and half of this.
He was allowed to publish his memoirs after properly groveling to you,
the latest leader of the country.
Of course,
he also had his public image greatly rehabilitated by Brezhnev and order to
shore up his own popularity while brash and have used Zuckoff for his
popularity.
He did not trust him in politics after all of the accusations of burner partism
over the years and depart from writing his memoirs.
Zuckoff would remain retired for the rest of his remaining years.
Wednesday,
golf for retired.
His thoughts went to writing his memoirs and he started working on reminisces
and reflections.
He also spends a lot of time just relaxing,
hunting and socializing with people are used to know as he wrote his memoirs.
However,
his health continued to steadily decline,
is balanced with heart disease.
Earlier in life were a sign of things to come and in 1967 Zuckoff has another
heart attack that hit him so hard.
It took away the use of the left side of his body for his remaining years.
During his struggle with heart disease.
His wife Galina,
was attending to Edmonds,
trying to help him get his memoirs finished.
Finally,
in 1969 they were completed,
passed the sensors and published he became the most popular accounts of the war
from a Soviet perspective,
selling millions of copies around the world,
Fan letters and suggestions poured into comms mailbox in the tens of thousands
wishing him well and praising him for his life's loyal work.
Unfortunately,
for Zuckoff,
this resurgence there is old popularity was not to be enjoyed for long.
In 1973 his second wife Galina passed away and Zuckoff was left entirely alone.
There's memoirs were published,
his life's work was done.
His children were accounted for and his was gone without our physical and
emotional support and with years of heart disease building up,
he didn't tout,
lost her.
By Long.
In 1974 the final heart attack took him and the Soviet Union lost their greatest
military hero of the age.
When Zuckoff died,
he was given a state funeral led by Brezhnev who had his ashes laid to rest in
honor at the Kremlin wall.
[inaudible] legacy will always enjoying some controversy,
but there is no doubt that he was one of the greatest military minds of world
war two and one of the greatest men of the Soviet Union.
So I really hope you found that video interesting.
If you'd please do give us a like below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos just like this a couple of times a week,
looking at all sorts of people from history,
not just military leaders that are running the gamut of a bunch of people.
So subscribe to that and hit that bell so you actually find out and bounce our
videos.
If you want to watch something right now and go check out.
One of the other videos were thinking too on the screen now,
and as always,
thanks for watching.